mais ce week-end plus précisément ce
dimanche nous voterons pour les
élections régionales et départementales
alors quels sont les principaux enjeux
de ces deux scrutins à venir et les 20
et 27 juin pour y répondre juste in
brazil est avec nous bonsoir de la
rédaction de tv 78 qu'en est il déjà
pour les régionales justin alors 11-10
se présente déjà en ile-de-france la
favorite du scrutin
eh bien c'est la présidente sortante
valérie pécresse en 2015 elle avait
repris à la région à la gauche en
ile-de-france la liste est républicain
portait donc par valérie pécresse avait
obtenu 43 % du suffrage face au parti
socialiste 42% et le rassemblement
national front national à l'époque
arrivé en troisième position avec 14%
des voix
elle fait face cette année à une gauche
divisée clémentine autain pour la france
insoumise julien bayou pour l' europe
ecologie les verts et puis audrey pulvar
pour soutenue par le parti socialiste
une dispersion qui va forcément peser
dans la balance ce dimanche et se
ressentir donc dans les résultats
même si les listes de gauche s'unissent
pour le second tour valérie pécresse en
tête des intentions de vote pourrait
l'emporter et donc enchaîner un second
mandat voilà pour les régionales quels
sont les enjeux côté département dans
les yvelines la question qui se pose est
de savoir si la droite va faire un
nouveau chelem cette année comme c'était
le cas en 2015 lors des dernières
élections départementales la liste
ensemble pour les yvelines de droite et
du centre représentait donc par pierre
bédier président du département avait
fait un carton plein en remportant les
21 cantons
et puis aussi particularité du parti
présidentiel qui présente seulement cinq
binômes dans le padd département cette
année et le rassemblement national
présente vingt binôme et un soutien et
quels sont les cantons à surveiller ce
week-end alors le canton de
mantes-la-jolie fait partie et des
cantons à suivre puisque c'est celui de
pierre bédier président sortant avec
donc sept binômes en lice autres cantons
également à surveiller celui de
bonnières sur seine avec laurent morin
pour représenter le rn et patrick
stefanini pour la droite un canton qui
verra s'opposer à des hommes politiques
expérimentés et puis le canton de
trappes va-t-il rebasculer à la gauche
cette année c'est le maire de trappes
très médiatisée ces derniers mois se
présente face au maire de la commune
voisine là
hier nicolas d'un bilan et puis autre
enjeu justine et non des moindres la
participation exactement donc lors de la
dernière à des dernières élections en
2015 le taux de participation aux
régionales au premier tour était de 45%
54% pour le deuxième tour du côté des
départementales 45% au premier tour
également un peu moins au second tour
avec 42 % de participation
alors qu'à gori on sait que ce ne sont
pas les élections qui attire le plus de
monde d'autant plus que les deux
scrutins cette année se déroulent en
même temps ce qui court circuite un peu
les informations et surtout la clarté à
des messages et sans oublier qu'on est
évidemment en pleine crise sanitaire
donc ces facteurs font qu on peut
s'attendre à un faible taux de
participation cette année pour les
élections